I don't like the narrative of the shark
it is weird that like because they know
how to beat up a short no no's yeah and
if you wanna make me squeeze its balls
[Music]
we have Rainn Wilson coming in any
thoughts about this leading up to Rainn
Wilson coming into our studio Ian I got
so excited
ten years ago I exclusively exclusively
used his quotes to pick up women in
chats remember AI am sure you would I
like would use office quotes as like my
way message yeah and that's so funny I
was like yeah you know he's like
handsome and rugged and cool he's got a
whole team coming with him Rainn Wilson
[Music]
or me I hate to be that person I I don't
like when people go it's nice to meet
you it's nice to see you or yeah you
okay what's the story okay we it's
actually a good story um we met at the
Tonight Show in 2009 it was my first
time doing stand-up on the Tonight Show
and you were the guest on the show it
was you me and I was filling in for
Paula Abdul cuz she had you know a
problem probably at the time woke up not
feeling great so they call me the
morning of and and they asked me to fill
in for Paula Abdul and I did stand up in
the second chair position which is
unheard of oh wow and then Hoobastank
was the music very weird i what a weird
and somewhat lame assemblage of talent
for a talk show I'm sorry so excited
that you were on you made it legitimate
and so exciting
I mean it was but here's the thing
here's the thing yeah my my celebrity
star has waned in the sky of celebrity
which maybe is a good thing but now like
I can't be like a first guest so funny
how that works how like you know like
when the office was on and we were
getting nominated for would beg me to
come on Letterman and be the first guest
and stuff and now it's just like oh hey
I'm promoting this big movie could I be
in there you've been through each side
of it where you've seen you've you've
gone you've been the first what does
that feel like do you even let it get
you to care I mean does it you know it's
it dings your ego a little bit but for
me I don't I don't really care I you
know i i i i i had a great run i I
wasn't I'm a weird-looking doofus so you
know it was such a great ride to get on
that show and get to do that so it's all
fine yeah yeah and your first seat on
this show today
[Laughter]
I actually I remember I crept into your
dressing room when you were on the couch
talking to Jay Leno because they didn't
give me a bar in my room and I need it I
was drinking at the time and I was like
I need a beer before I go out there and
do my television day like I don't go on
stage without a beard me so I stole a
beer from your from your room and
chugged it right before I went onstage
nice to you or was I can of course you
were nice to me you were so nice times
when I've been a dick I'm sure but like
you know we all can be dicks but in in
that kind of setting and I'm another
piece of talent on the you were so
lovely and I even it was such an
embarrassing moment for me because I
went back and watched it and I didn't
realize it at the time but you were so
lovely because I finished my set and I
walked over to the couch and you go oh
so hilarious so funny and I go thanks
Dwight and I caught you on camera so
humiliatingly because I obviously knew
your name it happens to you a lot though
I'm assuming sure yeah it happens all
the time
yeah yet usually not like other fellow
performers in Hollywood guys like Dwight
Dwight yo
Dwight can you get a selfie like Dwight
oh I get that a lot
say everybody I want to say you're so
charming friendly that and and relevant
yes I will take a selfie with you like
what's your what's your point you yeah
nice no um no I I try it to always give
a nice photo to a respectful fan who's
just being a decent human being and I'm
obviously a fan of the show but like
drunken frat boys who are neither nor a
frat right are is you know shouting
Dwight across the street I died yeah
they should know shouldn't they
shouldn't get when they were on
[Laughter]
[Music]
sorry Nikki no I know it's your show the
thing I went and did a play in Chicago
and the people like people in New York
in LA they're pretty savvy about
celebrity and they're like and you could
tell like they recognize you but they're
like okay there's celebrities around
whatever we'll be respectful in Chicago
I don't think they get any yeah yeah
those we're talking about myself as a
celebrity but you know celebrity
whenever I'm a recognizable former
sitcom figure and but they just go great
they just went crazy and Chicago I mean
they would paw it my clothes and grab my
arm on the subway I just like be shaking
a girl came up with tears running down
they don't get any kind of celebrities
you would be huge what's your deal who
are you recognize on the street and he's
not he's not been on anything like
people just great what is your name
again yeah in finance he fight financed
by Dan by Dan financed with the D dance
anyways hilarious he's yeah I feel like
I want to manage your career let's do it
I feel like I want to like take him to
Hollywood and be like this is Ian
finance yes and he's an actor I mean he
he will be someone that people will be
screaming whatever your character name
is like me in Chicago baby I love that
because yeah you you are a character
actor guy much like rain with great eye
I looked I was researching you this
morning you weren't almost famous which
is one of my favorite movies my first
film and I know tell me about that
experience and tell me about booking
that movie how exciting that was I mean
that's a huge movie to book as your
first film yeah you know I put myself on
tape in New York and then you know
didn't hear anything like I didn't hear
about anything for most of the auditions
that and then moved had moved to LA and
then just got a
all like you've got a call back and and
I was like holy and they were like
you can read the script but it's under
lock and key you have to go into Cameron
Crowe's production office you have to
sign in you have to sign an NDA and you
can only read it in the office and you
can't take it with you or take any
pictures they confiscate any cameras or
phone so when it was like this sacred
pilgrimage of like going down to vinyl
films in Santa Monica and they brought
it out like on a silver tray there was
like a chorus of angels like the
suitcase in Pulp Fiction and he and it
was in it's truly one of the great
screenplays ever written especially the
full one the like 200 page version full
screenplay is it's a novel you laugh you
cry or just and I sat there and read the
whole thing's like crying laughs and of
course I was just auditioning for small
roles but it was super cool and then I
went and met Cameron Crowe's one of the
coolest human beings and I'm sitting on
a little chair in his office and he
comes in in flip flops and sits
cross-legged on the floor in front of me
with a little like handicam to film the
audition but totally lick disarming like
hey man I totally love that
audition you did you were so funny and
like let's figure out let's go let's
read these things and you have any ideas
like what you want to play or how you
want to play it and just totally
collaborative and very very different
experience than auditioning for most
people yeah I an ideal audition I would
say because you you felt comfortable and
he was rooting for you in that moment
yeah and he already liked what you had
done and and you did do something really
you made a lot of hard choices on that
character I mean it really stands out to
me as soon as and I didn't reven realize
it was you until I read that this
morning was like oh my god yeah you were
you worked at Rolling Stone in the
character yeah the editor yeah he was an
editor at rolling stone Dave and now I'm
blanking on the name cuz cuz he's an
actual based on natural person him yes
and he's and I met him he came by the
set when we were shooting and he was
Cameron's
mentor as a young writer so Wow
in fact when I read the script there was
an amazing scene of this guy Dave with
the kid at the airport and it's a 2-page
scene all about like writing and you
know what it means to fall in love with
a band but don't fall in love too much
because you've got to be a journalist
and and just about life and I was like
so when I got cast that scene was still
in the script and then they called me
like a month or two later and like that
scenes been cut you get this role in
your so yeah it's it's still a man you
still really shine in that film and um I
just love that that was your first film
cuz what had you been doing up into that
point I I went to NYU and I was doing
theater in New York for the most part
yeah it's been 10 years doing
Shakespeare and just little plays some
big plays I was in a few Broadway things
and and regional theatre and I just I
went for classical I'm not in the not in
the comedy world people always think I
was like a stand-up or a sketch comedian
or improv guy I never did any of that
stuff I just played weird characters in
plays which kind of worked for Dwight
you know to transition into that role
from from doing Shakespearean clowns to
Dwight is actually not that far away of
a shift yeah you bring that to that role
that really makes a lot of sense to me
that you yeah it's uh I want to ask you
about the movie that you are currently
in and out and that is the reason you're
here it's called the Meg it's based on
the I didn't know what it was I just
thought it was about a girl in a
sorority she's haunting the sorority
it's the Megalodon which is the
extinguisher yes and this is a this is a
monster movie and and you play a
scientist
no lad you did your research wrong my
favorite part of the trailers when you
tell Jason Statham that he had an
attitude problem yeah no I so I play
Morris who is a billionaire
an industrialist who funded the whole
scientific operation and built this
underwater lab that the scientists in it
discover this kind of like this secret
area of the ocean that's never been
uncovered before and they go down under
it and then they unleash the Megalodon
who comes up into the waters to chomp on
thousands of people yes and you shot
this in New Zealand shot in New Zealand
amazing as three months in New Zealand
which is the most incredible country on
earth
yeah it's incredible nair before i'd
never been there before it's amazing if
you get a chance to go it's a long ways
but man it's it's spectacular and yeah
it's like one of those dream jobs it's
like oh you're gonna pay me all this
money and I'm gonna be in New Zealand
with Jason Statham and cool this is
awesome but you spent a lot of time on a
boat fellas yeah so we spent a few weeks
on a boat out in the actual ocean and
shot some stuff out there but most of it
was that same boat that we're on in the
ocean it's so weird how they do these
things in movies they they made another
version they made two boats and then
that second one they cut in half and
then we were shot on the back of that
half a boat in a tank in a giant giant
tank about the size of a soccer field
Wow that's like six feet deep and they
put that boat in the tank and then in
that giant green screens around it and
the cameras and they could kind of
rotate the boat and and turn it and
stuff like that so we yeah we spent
months yeah on that on that boat but we
had a lot of fun it's a really fun
ensemble of people I mean it sounds like
it and and you were there during the
election you said you were like out on
the water yeah yeah I'm just staying I'm
staying in New Zealand the I was out on
the harbour and we were shooting this
chase scene with a the shark is chasing
about to devour Jason Statham and that
it was like 1:00 p.m. but the polls had
already closed and and I was just hit
keep hitting reef
on my CNN app results were coming in and
there were they were only two other
Americans there were it was Paige
Kennedy who doesn't didn't care Jon
Turteltaub who's directing the film who
was so busy you know directing 150
million dollar film that he didn't have
the time to care it was just me and that
other people are Australians and yeah
yeah Icelandic people and people from
England and they did they did kind of
cared but didn't really but it was
[Music]
Donald Trump did you grow up liking
these let me just talk to you about
sharks how did you feel about sharks
going into this what was your knowledge
of them are you scared of them are you
someone who enjoys the ocean I yeah I
like the ocean I'm a real wimp around
the ocean so people say oh do sharks
scary it's like yeah sharks scare me but
you know what else scares me salmon yeah
[Applause]
see we would squeeze out by all manner
the water the tides like that's the
thing that scares me the most is like
Riptide yeah you got a swim parallel to
the shore there you gotta have all these
plans you got a bunch of girls you got
to remember all these things out there
bunch and then those thing is kind of
what you do the main thing that you have
to do which is seems so cute 'iv is to
just float there and do nothing that
sounds like something the sharks put in
your head
around that's when the Sharks go so you
just lay there yeah I kind of smell you
and then maybe have a your surf suit on
a wetsuit and then they're like ass I
mean most shark attacks are just a shark
tasting you and going luck so when
people get bit by sharks it's usually
just just a sample have you tried to
taste a seal I think racist against you
thank you so much I I was doing um as
part of shark week I was doing shark
after dark this like show and we were
talking about all these things and and
the bite I would love to get bit by sure
if I can guarantee to get bit by a shark
and then not die from it like a little
teething or like a scar a shark scar I
think that girl that has one arm is so
cool then you know the girl that was
young you got bit the surfer I think she
is so I mean I'm not I don't want that
but like I was a shark week with the guy
who lost his arm or arm no there's a guy
covered in scars with one arm who had it
lost an Australian guy to a shark Wow
and they're like wow that's so cool
we're gonna make you the host yeah I
think sharks are so fascinating and I I
think that I care about them a lot and
and wants people to know about them and
know that although these movies are fun
and sensational
lized and and make us scared of sharks
that they're really not there's so many
more things to worry about than sharks
I'm more worried about humanity but also
like it is even if you died by shark one
time I borrowed my handyman's van to go
down to Home Depot and pick up some
stuff and I was and I pulled out kind of
under the street light traffic and
started going oh the seat was like too
far back so I went bent down to kind of
pull the seat forward to hit the little
thing and then my finger got stuck like
literally as it slid forward pull it
over my finger it didn't like chop it
off or anything but it was like weirdly
stuck and I was trying to drive this big
van with my finger under the thing and I
was already kind of in the traffic and I
couldn't find a place I am gonna die in
this van with my finger under the seat
and they're gonna take a photograph of
me TMZ is gonna come over and I'm gonna
look like I'm gonna look so grotesque
and pathetic like in your will it should
say like hey if I die like that
plant a shark on the sea you can make
big money think about that like those
were those times where you go oh my god
I could have just died just then and
that would have been the story I always
think about on Dawson's Creek
Dawson's dad died because he was licking
an ice cream cone and it like fell off
into the seat next to him and he tried
to like reach yeah or they were making a
bologna sandwich by reaching in the back
seat it's like a cousin of my grandma or
something but I was that's a dumb way to
go I fell into a river one and when I
fell in I went wow I spun around and
that would have been my last words
for some reason I think that's how
you're gonna go anyway you get some kind
of weird disease and on your deathbed
you'll go Rainn Wilson thank you so much
for being here you're such a great guest
thank you guys this was a this was a
hoot a true treat for all of us we were
so excited to meet you and see you and
and and you just blew us you're just
awesome Rainn Wilson everyone we'll be
back with more show after this
[Music]
you